Irene qué otros detalles se conocen del
ataque contra la torre de televisión y
de otros posibles bombardeos después del
anuncio del Ministerio de defensa ruso
pues se sabe que con ustedes decían han
muerto cinco personas y aquí esto este
ataque a interrumpido
comunicaciones a través
Rusia Por otra parte estaba atacando a
infraestructura subrañada desde hace
días atacado plantas plantas de gas
depósitos de petróleo
ecológico y esto ha sido un poco la
novedad de los Últimos Días
Pues sí es el correcto esa información
es la que tenemos Nosotros también y hay
que decir que la ciudad se está
preparando una forma increíble hay sacos
de arena
blindados civiles armados que han armado
múltiples puesto de control más de lo
que habíamos visto en los últimos días y
que se está realmente preparando
resistida a estas a estos ataques Aunque
bueno permanece la duda de cómo se
llevarán a cabo ese ataques porque sí
concentra son ataques aéreos o de todas
formas se concentran sobre el parlamento
ucraniano o por ejemplo
el ayuntamiento